[Music]
hi guys I'm Charlotte McKinny and we're
here at the GQ photo
[Music]
shoot my dad's Bahamian so growing up we
practically lived in the Bahamas all
summer so it's kind of my go-to spot a
day for me on the beach in the summer is
bikinis it has to be nice out you know
some fun activities like paddle boarding
maybe some Rosé in the day I'm so for
spitty dipping I think in the summer
late
night it's um you're with a fun friend
it's a fun sport no that sounds so bad I
have been stung by a jellyfish and my
mom said the best thing to do is have
someone's pee on it and I told her don't
be dare I will not let you pee on me and
my mom tried peeing on me on the beach
in Miami as a young child so I'm scarred
for life happy summer
[Music]
guys